je vais vous demander de prendre cet
iPad à vos côtés et de regarder la
première photo
ce qui est extraordinaire avec cette
photo c'est qu'on voit des milliers de
gens qui au lieu de regarder le
spectacle le film pourquoi le film t-il
c'est un moment extraordinaire c'est un
moment unique puisque c'est le moment où
il va devenir le plus grand marqueur de
la NBA c'est un moment historique qu'on
se prive de vivre tout au désir que nous
sommes de l'avoir vécu les gens qui
filment ce moment il sacrifie
l'expérience qu'il pourrait faire de ce
moment historique à la possibilité de
dire qu'ils étaient là il y a deux
enjeux dans cette histoire il y a mettre
le monde à distance
en le filmant c'est-à-dire se tenir loin
de lui et il y a aussi confié à des
objets le soin de son souvenir à ma
place c'est aussi la raison pour
laquelle on filme c'est à dire que on
filme les choses pour être certain non
pas de ne pas les oublier mais pour être
certain de pouvoir les oublier
puisqu'elles seront quelque part le
résultat c'est un déni du présent parce
que l'intention c'est de garder cet
événement dans le passé dans la mémoire
donc de le filmer pour cette raison là
et dans le même temps de le voir
via son téléphone et donc de le mettre à
distance donc ils sont privés de vivre
la chose par le le goût de s'en souvenir
sur cette photo on aperçoit une personne
qui ne fume pas la scène feel night le
fondateur de Nike qui a un certain âge
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire justement le
fait que lui ne filme pas cette scène
avec un téléphone portable pour vous il
y a deux façons de le regarder celui-là
soit on se dit c'est un homme démodé
hors du coup loin de tout c'est un
vieillard qui sait même pas qu'on peut
filmer ces choses-là qui de profitent
pas de la possibilité de filmer et
d'immortaliser ce moment-là donc soit on
le regarde comme ça soit on le regarde
comme le seul homme à jeun au milieu
d'un troupeau de spectateurs
ivre qui sont convaincus de vivre la
chose alors qu'ils ont interposé leur
téléphone confortable entre eux-mêmes et
le spectacle il y a vraiment deux façons
de le regarder et ces deux façons de le
regarder correspondent je crois à
l'ambivalence de celui qu'on a appelé
l'homme démodé qu'est-ce que c'est un
homme démodé c'est quelqu'un qui par ses
comportements par ses attachements par
ses goûts par son obstination ou par son
mauvais caractère peut-être parfois
refuse de céder aux modes du présent
mais celui à qui on reproche d'être
dépassé c'est aussi celui qui dans la
conscience collective se voit parfois
dotée nanti d'un savoir particulier
d'une façon de voir qui n'a pas encore
été altérée par ces outils modernes et
qui donc parfois peut avoir la bonne
idée alors on l'a vu avec ce match de
basket on le voit souvent lors des
concerts aujourd'hui beaucoup de gens
filment les choses plutôt que de les
vivre complètement mais en parallèle il
y a des pratiques comme la méditation la
sophrologie le yoga qui connaissent un
vrai succès alors qu'elle consiste
justement à être connecté à soi-même
dans le moment présent et qu'est-ce que
ça dit de notre époque la coexistence
entre des individus qui filment un
basketteur et
un nombre conséquent d'individus qui
justement se lance dans la sophrologie
dans la méditation et adore qu'on les
prenne en photo tandis qu'ils se livrent
à des exercices de sophrologie montrant
par la même qu'ils sont loin d'avoir
guéri du mal dont ils veulent sortir
quiconque à l'habitude avec son
téléphone portable de mettre le réel à
distance peut tout à fait être celui qui
de temps en temps pose son portable les
teint ou le met sur mode avion pour
soudain renouer avec la vie vraiment
vécue dans des exercices dont c'est
l'unique raison d'être dans le cas des
des images dans le cas des selfies dans
le cas des de l'utilisation que nous
faisons de nos de nos smartphones la
philosophie permet de comprendre que le
sens de la vue c'est celui qui suppose
d'être à distance et qui donc nous
éloigne du monde tout en nous donnant la
capacité de le regarder dans son
ensemble et qu'en somme un appareil
photo ou un smartphone un smartphone ne
fonctionne pas autrement il nous donne
le sentiment de capturer quelque chose
alors que c'est précisément le moment où
on ne
Montaigne dans les essais à la toute fin
des aisselles le dernier chapitre
résumant une formule toute la sagesse
dont il est capable c'est l'homme le
plus sage de tous les temps en montagne
et bien toute sa sagesse tient en deux
tautologie quand je danse je danse et
quand je dors je dors autrement dit je
suis tout à moi-même quand j'agis et
c'est exactement ce qu'on ne fait pas
quand alors qu'on va avoir un match de
basket on préfère filmer le panier
plutôt que le regarder et l'applaudir il
est plus difficile dans la vie de vivre
les choses que de se filmer en train de
les vivre
la vraie difficulté dans la vie c'est
l'étonnante simplicité qu'il faut avoir
pour vivre ce qu'on vit pour danser
quand on danse pour dormir quand on dort
pour réfléchir quand on pense etc c'est
à dire pour être le contemporain de
soi-même et le grand paradoxe c'est que
pour être le contemporain de soi-même
il ne faut pas se regarder soi-même si
vous vous regardez faire si vous vous
demandez ce que vous êtes en train de
faire vous perdez la main sur ce que
vous faites en fait l'expression clé
pour qualifier celui qui est capable de
ne pas se regarder faire au moment où il
fait
c'est la naissance de soi c'est le
contraire de la conscience de soi la
conscience de soi c'est le pianiste qui
se dit qu'est-ce que je suis en train de
faire là c'est le virtuose qui du coup
fait une fausse note parce qu'il se
regarde c'est le funambule qui tombe
parce qu'il se demande ce qu'il est en
train de faire sur son fil entre deux
immeubles la conscience de soi c'est
l'érection qui disparaît parce qu'on se
demande si elle va tenir c'est tout ce
qui est de l'ordre de la conscience de
soi
était un handicap à l'action alors que
ce que Saint-Augustin appelle et
vladimirgent qu'elle évite après lui la
naissance de soi c'est à dire l'oubli du
mois dans l'action c'est aussi ce qui
nous permet d'agir la naissance de soi
c'est le fait de ne pas se regarder
faire c'est le fait d'être tout entier à
ce que nous faisons
plutôt qu'à la personne de celui qui
fait